yoder's of everybody mad Luigi here and
there's been some more fallout 4 news
that's come out today so I thought I
would just let you guys know what I
found out so first thing is that the
main menu for Fallout 4 has been leaked
by a streamer who has the picture as you
can see here today it was just a
vertical picture so I just zoomed it on
some parts to show you guys and it looks
pretty minimalistic however I think it
looks pretty I think looks pretty cool
but just what I really think is cool is
the fact that it looks like it could be
in real time so like right now that
picture of the garage it could be like a
current like a video of the garage of
what it's like or wherever you pause the
game and then save and leave it out it's
like the last time you have the game
loaded it might be in that areas and
when you continue the game you'll just
be put straight into that area and also
like again if it was real time and stuff
like the armor as you make
customizations the armor or something
like that it would change which I think
would be a really really cool main menu
I need to be a lot cooler than a static
one and that doesn't look like it's
going to be I would be really surprised
if they have that one picture be the
main menu for the entire game all the
time forever so that's why I'm pretty
I'm I'm pretty excited about that it
looks it looks like it's gonna be in
real time and now also is nuka-cola
quantum is going to be a real thing in
the real world so as you can see there's
a tweet by fall out that says raise your
AP and it's saying that you can get some
quantum nuka-cola from target on
November 10 so you're gonna have to wait
a little bit but so until the game comes
out as easy as you can see there's some
actual nuka-cola quantum right there
like you see there's three things and if
you go onto the target website it'll
show they have nuka-cola on there except
it uh it's out of stock since they don't
put it in till November 10th because
obviously that's when the game comes out
and it's cool and so I thought that was
pretty cool where there's gonna be some
actual nuclear Cola and then there's a
bobblehead guy next to him vault boy
bobblehead and then there's the pin-up
girl with some nuka-cola products and
what's actually really cool is that
nuclear coal epistle that she has is in
the art design for the weapon so it
looks like that will actually be a
weapon in the game or something I don't
think that one specifically but on
nuclear like a small
call a pistol that looks like it shoots
nuclear Cola and it's just just really
small and looks really close to that and
it was in the art of games it looks like
that could be a thing so we could have a
nuclear coal pistol in the game a
real-time menu and real nuka-cola
quantum which I know I'm definitely
going to look into buying some so that's
basically the video is just to post any
videos like couple pictures and just
some news that I found out and follow
for that I thought you guys would be
intrigued about so if you like this
stuff then keep looking at my channel i
will be posting lots more fall for
especially when the games comes out and
yeah thank you for watching hope you
enjoyed peace out